you know what dudes it's it's real funny
because I've noticed
around a third of guys when you unplug
them from society's comforting lies they
they go back to them it could be more
could be half you know but it seems like
it's at least about a third of dudes
like to go back to the Comfort they like
to go back to what is uh familiar you
know if you will
um you know they've seen the code of the
Matrix as they would say they've
unplugged they see the world for what it
is the reality of relationships money
self-care you know dating all that stuff
and they're like nope
not gonna have it I like the [__] that I
believe before I want to continue to
sleep walk through life
it happens
to a lot of guys
um you know in my book which you know is
sort of the basis of this podcast series
if you guys haven't got the book
definitely get it um there's a second
edition that'll be out later on this
year
and I've got the second book which will
be in be out shortly after the second
edition
um with some more stuff just kind of
diving deeper into the rabbit hole on
this and um I just think it's a good
idea to have all these ideas and stuff
in more than just video format paper's
always a little more durable than
YouTube who knows what happens you know
with this content in the future I'm sure
it's not going to be around forever so
that's why I'm doing it that way
um
but yeah you'll
I mean I've done
well over a thousand maybe 1500 uh
consults calls with guys privately
um every show I take at least
I don't know somewhere between half
dozen to a dozen call-ins every show
there's 81 episodes in this show
um I've done them on the before the
train wreck as well we took Hollins when
I was working with Sean
um I've talked to a lot of people and
I've noticed a lot of dudes like to
let's go back to what's comforting
don't want to do what is real don't want
to do what works doesn't don't want to
do what I know women respond to don't
want to do what
um the facts demonstrate I want to go
back to my comforting lies
I got an article that I'm gonna kind of
zip through in this kind of opening
segment on cognitive bias because I
think that's a big part of it
but um yeah it's a reality you know guys
will literally say
the thank you this is saved my life I
had the muzzle of a you know 45 you know
my I was about to chew on it the other
day and uh you know without you without
you know the group of guys in the
community in a group whatever
I don't know where I'd be and then
they'll just say uh oh but you're a
bunch of misogynists or I don't like you
know what you're talking about today
it's weird it's it's very very common
and
I don't think we
as guys that have unplugged and continue
to do the work and take ownership
um and be accountable and hold others
that want to be accountable accountable
as well
should really care to be honest with you
um there's always going to be
crabs in a bucket you know as they say
um you throw a bunch of crabs in a
bucket apparently the way that they
operate is when one starts to climb out
the ones in the bottom will grab them
and pull them back down
so this is this is purportedly how it
works with Crustaceans and buckets
works the same way with dudes I see it
over and over again and you can beat
yourself up and get sad over it like
I've seen comments from uh guys in my
discussion forum I have a private
discussion forum
um I don't mention enough people always
tell me why don't you talk about this
more put the ticker down at the bottom
so I got a community
um yeah but I've seen guys in the
community now and they'll be all you
know this this satin the other thing
makes sense
and know that you know we'll just use
checks as an example because that seems
to be like the driving force for for a
lot of guys still is
um you know this chick will be a total
train wreck she'll be toxic she'll be
narcissistic she'll be manipulative
she'll she'll be the kind of person that
can ruin you personally and financially
by going back to them and they'll go
back to them anyway
they know what they're like it's like a
building is marked and it says this is
the slaughterhouse
and they just March back into it knowing
exactly what they're marching into and
their friends are you know standing
there
on the way while the guys walking into
the slaughterhouse being like Yo dude
are you sure you want to do this you
know this is really not the best idea
and dude just keeps Marching In
it's March into that slaughterhouse
and all you can do is just step aside
it's like look if that's the kind of
person you're gonna be if that's if
that's the way that you want to run your
life and you want to invite chaos into
it you want to can't complicate it
unnecessarily cool have fun
um but there's probably going to be some
distance made between you and those
people
um I don't have time for [__] in my
life and I don't encourage anybody to
tolerate [__] I mean look man when
you're younger
yeah you're gonna put up with some more
[__] your younger kid you're in your
20s you know
um you're still kind of figuring things
out right you're gonna put up with
people that do stuff like that it is
what it is right how do I how do I stop
my friends from doing this and
um you know another one that pops up a
lot that I've seen
um even in my discussion forum too is
how do you save men that don't want to
be saved
and I'll tell you what the answer to
that is is you don't
you don't they don't want to be saved
don't save them [__] it who cares
let them go let them March into that
slaughterhouse let them do what they're
gonna do
let them invite chaos into their lives
let them return to the train wreck
that's going to ruin them emotionally
financially intellectually all those
ways let them do what it is they're
going to do roll up your sleeves as I am
doing now and get on with the business
of what you get on with doing
and let them go
because
this is how
we should handle things I believe you
should put yourself first you should
make yourself your own mental point of
origin you should allocate your [__] to
the things that are truly fuckworthy
right talk about that in one of the
chapters of my book managing your energy
talk about other things in my book like
managing your endocrine system but
specifically you need to manage your
energy and only dispense it
on things on matters on people that are
that it's truly worthy of your time I
mean one of the things that I'll that
I'll get you know from time to time
you've you know if you've watched enough
of my podcasts or enough of my videos
um you know you'll hear me talk about
about this notion of [__] you know
and that's ask by the way not ass it's
ask whole right [__] and all that
means is
you're asking the same thing over and
over again but doing nothing with the
information that you're provided and
you're reverting right back to what it
is that you're doing that's an [__]
right so if you have people in your life
right now that are doing things that you
know asking questions or asking for
advice they want help with something you
provide a solution you know you provide
the advice uh that that would be useful
and then they do nothing with it in a
few weeks later a day later or a month
later or whatever happens to be they
come back and ask you the same [__]
again just look at them and say you're
being an [__] what's that explain it
to them this is what you're doing I
don't deal with people like that I
already told you what to do go do it
[__] off right
you're gonna get a lot of people like
that you know
your
you know your boy is
40 years like Old Dogs new tricks very
very true
I can retrain a 20 year old man before I
can train retrain a 40 or 50 year old
man
right I can tell him the exact same
thing
and I do
but the older guy because they have
decades more of societal programming
decades more of
all those marketing messages and
[__] and TV shows and sitcoms and
Men ain't [__] you know men are useless
all that stuff coming at them women are
great they're beautiful at any size you
know use my pronouns whatever all that
stuff
because I've heard decades and Decades
of that stuff
to try to show them something completely
different and adopt it and use it
I believe is less likely than a 20 year
old who's only you know maybe been
hearing these messages for you know 15
years or so you know what is that age
when we start to become like
you you know where you start to develop
memories for me probably four three four
you know something like that so you know
you have 15 17 years
to untrain
um
programming that's not useful you can do
that a lot quicker than somebody that's
adopted that for 30 35 years 40 years 50
years
I've seen those guys go back a lot
not just the older guys but younger guys
too and I you know see them go back all
the time and it's like what the [__] are
you doing
all right why are you getting mad you
know the facts
I've said it before I'll say it again I
quoted it several times in different
parts of my book if you have a problem
with the facts
your problem isn't with the facts it's
with you I'm gonna spell it out I'm just
gonna say it
that's it
when you know something to be true
one plus one is two two plus two is four
if you're going to tell me all day long
that two plus two is five I don't give a
[__] believe whatever you want I'm
[__] done
I know what the facts are you've seen
what the facts are argue whatever you
want in whatever Direction you want go
think two plus two is five have fun
enjoy argue you know what go on Twitter
because that's where everybody likes to
go are you go on Twitter and argue with
those [__]
see if that's a good use of your time I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out